a r return
agenda a new clo new
name a
[Music]
render never be the
same if you've got a feeling
oh there's something you
like just switch your pronouns and
refuse to Swit them
back yeah all right
like to thank Donnie Osman for
that for not doing it the verdict they
rendered coddles the misgendered the
Michigan Supreme Court is prohibiting
all judges in that state from
misgendering anyone who comes before any
Court it passed two five to two with the
liberal justices voting for it and the
conservatives against it true liberal
justices just mandated what judges can
say although just saying mandating will
soon be outlawed as well comes after a
2021 case involving a transom who
demanded being addressed by they them
pronouns the state's lower court of
appeals finally chose to honor that
request and so this trans madness has
gone from the girl's bathroom to the
courtroom but for the per this they them
is the perfect legal strategy if you win
you walk out a free man but if you lose
you get to go to a woman's
prison it's a win-win as my stuttering
Uncle used to
say laugh are you laughing at my
stuttering Uncle he's probably watching
right now no I'm kidding he's
dead
H took a while digan um this is kind of
scary to me because there's no science
behind this this is all based on people
demanding things and the courtroom
should be immune to this it absolutely
should should and they it I'm surprised
that it's happening now because Demi
lado was kind of the peak of this
nonsense yeah a few months ago she said
she was going back to using she her
instead of just they them because it was
so exhausting and confusing yes to
everybody so can you imagine how cocked
up this court system is going to be when
the judge is addressing someone and the
defendant goes no it's them yeah and the
judge goes who it's them who it's them
yeah who yeah who did it so so so the
lawyer the lawyer will go so who
attacked you and and and they did you
mean there was more than one person no
they it's like who's on first I know our
audience will understand
that they were born then no it's true
they this is so illogical Casey this
goes against common sense what Ian what
Michigan never used to be like this well
that actually was one of the points that
one of the judges said they said oh well
they'll just have to pay more attention
in the footnotes footnotes are a thing
just just put it in the footnotes that
that they is referencing one person and
who it is they can say plaintiff they
can say defendant so that's a little
loophole that you get a little nugget
there um I'm the one in the orange
jumpsuit right now so I don't know but
you know what that's true I I what work
relase crew did you escape
from that was a flood I yeah I just ran
away up litter today or yes the highway
flooded um no what I was going to say
was MX I actually and maybe I'm just
naive or or didn't know this I had to
look it up as mck so they them would be
mck M Gutfeld not Mister oh wow I didn't
know that I had no idea MX or M which I
did I'm confused now you've confused me
even more this is terrible Tom you know
um this is basically a step towards
compelling this in everyday life once
it's in the courts right yeah and it's
quite dangerous but I agree with danan
it's it's almost like you're surprised
that this is happening now because most
people are starting to wake up and say
okay this was a little bit silly we got
a little goofy but there are certain
places like when you go into a college
campus the professors are still there
they're still acting like this is a
thing so we expect them to be last in
line but this is why I don't trust
judges I mean I don't when when a a
decision comes out of the courts they
say oh the court decided oh wow the
court decided it's like they're just
people and a lot of them are stupid
watch it I mean a lot of judges are
dumb yeah you're not on the 21st floor
with judge Janine easy for you to say
she's a good one Greg she's she's a good
one she's all right she's all right you
she's a she and you know who's good TV
judges judge wner would never go in for
this he' be like I'm not saying that
yeah he'd be like he she that's it yeah
exactly he she that that was something
else when I was growing up who was Pete
you know what this is this is um people
talk about freedom of speech this is
when they compel speech that's still an
attack on freedom of speech you do have
a right not to say things so if I were
in the courtroom and I say I'm not going
to be I'm not going to say they that and
they compel me to that's an attack on me
it is but this is what they do with big
institutions first in High by the way
all the law St students coming out have
lived in this nonsense you know yeah mck
shud the judge will you now like they're
used to that same thing in the military
right now they're compelling the same
cuz they use institutions that are more
hierarchical like the courts or like the
miracle where the military where you you
have free speech rights but you kind of
don't and so as a result if you don't
comply there's this nebulous land where
you would be charged or you will be
pushed out and then in the meantime the
inmates run the Asylum the privates in
the military run the Asylum or in this
case the criminals who cons object to
the use of the language on them all day
long this is such an interesting point
because the military is based on
hierarchy right the entire premise of
the military and because of this like
identity politics stuff it is completely
flipped and so you have like you have
people on the top obeying the people on
the bottom it's exactly I I we don't
need to get into the whole military
thing but it's what commanders today say
is their biggest problem yeah is they
can't maintain the grooming standards of
a private private shave you can't tell
me to shave shave exactly you've
misgendered me and now it's the
commander that's in trouble or the judge
that's in
trouble all being done out of fear they
don't agree they don't believe in this
crap they're just scared and it what
burns me up is you're going to have a
male rapist in courts demanding that
everybody call him a she and you have to
play that charade and it makes a mockery
of the whole system the whole thing's
premised on aive I would pick a sound
yeah yeah you can't call me a pronoun
I'm a sound you have to take your pants
off to make that
sound yeah how far can you go that's a
great that's a great Point denan
although I think you took it too
far hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else